we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
caller who says listen he likes what i
say he just doesn't like my face take a
listen to this how's it going david
caller here for us a new york just
wanted to say that like I think I would
agree with you on most things
politically think around the same page
just one criticism for a show like yes
face man it's just not working out I
don't I don't know if I'm asked with
words or maybe some plastic swords
reasserts but you you just pretty snugly
my guy yeah yeah he's probably work on
it but you know you're killing it with
the political thing thank you you know
you get that shame now and I could
probably watch it more but as a villain
listen this is someone who says if I had
a different face they would likely watch
more now why they can't just listen I
don't know but I love the the the new
term plastic surgery I think it's a
combination of surgery and sorcery and I
would love it if someone set that up as
a definition on urban dictionary quoting
the David Pakman show plastic surgery
the recommendation there we've got a
great bonus show for you today
join pakman.com to get instant access
i'll speak to you on the bonus show